some interesting legal news that I want
to go over relating to the ongoing legal
troubles of the failed former president
and his associates first and foremost
very interesting report from Bloomberg
prosecutors believe that they have the
evidence to charge Donald Trump on the
basis of the investigation connected to
the search warrant served at Mar-A-Lago
let's take a look at this Bloomberg
report Trump prosecutors see evidence
for obstruction charges no decision on
charges has been made by doj in records
probe that's an important detail a bunch
of tweets were floating around yesterday
sometimes I wonder can people actually
read news articles as soon as this was
published yesterday all sorts of tweets
started floating around a decision has
been made Trump is getting charged the
the sub headline is no decision on
charges has been made in that records
probe timing politics and debate over
charges are among the considerations and
that's an area of significant concern
that we should all be worried about and
we will get to it in a moment here's
what Bloomberg rights a group of justice
department prosecutors believe there is
enough evidence to charge Trump with
obstruction of justice but the path to
an actual indictment is far from Clear
the team that's part of the classified
records probe has not yet made a formal
recommendation to Merit Garland who
would ultimately approve or reject such
a move according to people familiar with
the matter it's also unlikely officials
would bring only obstruction charges
amid several other Trump investigations
into potential crimes now this is the
part that I don't love
in addition while some FBI agents oppose
bringing such a politically charged case
As Trump considers a 2024 presidential
bid others support action said the
people who asked for anonymity because
this is not yet public agents however
don't make final decisions the justice
department has publicly indicated
obstruction is part of its probe into
the mishandling of classified records
noting there was probable cause for the
charge in the August 5 FBI search
warrant application for Trump's
Mar-A-Lago estate no charges are likely
to be filed or publicly revealed before
the November 8 elections and perhaps
only after the Christmas holiday the
people said one other note here Frank
figluzzi former FBI assistant director
for counterintelligence said quote of
all the things Trump is being
investigated for around the country
obstruction of justice is a slam dunk
and I think he's going to be indicted I
don't see why a charge of obstruction of
justice couldn't be filed by the end of
the year so listen uh charge gym it's
time okay we've had enough of this it's
really simple consider I mean forget
about Georgia forget about sdny just
focusing on this case investigation
alone
um did the uh did authorities know that
Trump had these files
and then they went to him and said
you've got to return these files yes we
they knew he had them and they asked for
those files to be returned did Donald
Trump return them the answer is no we
know that because they found files when
they executed the search warrant at
Trump's Mar-A-Lago do we now know that
Donald Trump was aware that they had
files directed staff to move them
directed a lawyer to lie and claim that
they had been given back I mean all of
these obstructive acts yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes so is it time for an
indictment of course it is of course of
course it is now what I'm not thrilled
about is this discussion about FBI
agents do or don't want the charges uh
levied because it could impact the
midterms so they're going to wait until
later but then it could impact Trump if
he decides to run in 2024 or whatever
listen
if they're
are charges that follow logically from
the evidence
not charging Trump because it might have
a political impact is just a political a
decision as saying let's charge him in
order to make it have a political impact
the a political thing to do here is that
those in law enforcement look at the
evidence they compare the evidence to
the law and they decide is there
sufficient evidence that a law was
broken such that we are going to Levy
charges you don't calculate the timing
based on political effect or whatever
else think back to the 2016 election by
the way where then FBI director James
Comey did one press conference about
Hillary Clinton's emails and then as far
as we knew that was it there weren't
going to be charges coming etc etc and
then right before the 2016 election for
some reason that we still don't really
understand James Comey does another
press conference about Hillary's miles
and we now believe we can't say any one
thing led to Trump winning and Hillary
losing but it was certainly another
little factor that served as a reminder
of oh yeah that thing even though
obviously no charges are coming that may
have pushed some people away from
Hillary Clinton and to Donald Trump if
there was any politically oriented
politically motivated timing for the FBI
doing something it would be that
here we have enough probable cause
for the search warrant to be executed we
now have colloquially speaking as
laypeople all of the elements that make
up obstruction by Donald Trump knowingly
directing people to lie and hide
documents all these different things and
at this point this idea of well we don't
we don't necessarily want to charge him
because it might affect a future run for
president he hasn't even announced well
opting not to charge for that very
reason is also a politically motivated
decision and it's absolutely pathetic it
is just as politically charged not to
charge someone because it might hurt
their chances at winning an elected
office as it is to say well let's
deliberately charge him now if the
evidence is there and the investigation
has been completed and it points to this
person likely committed this crime then
you just have to Levy charges and that's
it we will see if it happens it's not
going to happen before the November
election we it's abundantly clear at
this point in time but if and when it
happens when will it be I often have a
very hectic schedule and I don't always
have the time to plan the exact
nutrition of all of my meals but our
sponsor athletic greens just makes it
easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below